[Musique]
bonsoir heureux de vous retrouver pour
ce nouveau 7,8 les invités voici les
titres seulement 10 10 avril nous
recevons amaya l'humoriste et
réalisatrice de rendez-vous en banlieue
inconnue une vidéo parodique tourné à
saint rémy les chevreuse le sketch
remporté un franc succès sur youtube
avec plus de 150000 vue et puis la
batterie située à guyancourt fête ses 10
ans nous ferons un point sur l'évolution
de la salle de concert à l'occasion de
son anniversaire avec stéphane ridard
chargé de la programmation on début de
ce set 8 les invités avec amaya
l'humoriste et réalisatrice de
rendez-vous en banlieue inconnue une
vidéo sur youtube qui totalisent plus de
150000 vue je vous laisse voir un
extrait en banlieue
wouah
on peut y aller par et france soir
j'avais déjà entendu parler de la
banlieue mais je savais pas du tout à
quoi m'attendre en fait je pensais pas
qu'ils puissent y avoir de la vie après
le périphérique
après un éprouvant voyage de 45 minutes
nous arrivons enfin au terminus du rer b
là nous retrouvons iv margot malgré la
barrière de la langue qui nous sépare
nous partageons avec eux une même joie
beaucoup d'émotion dans notre coeur qui
bat très très vite vous merci
nous sommes très touchés de votre visite
à mayer bon voir comme ça alors cette
idée cette vidéo il ya vraiment des
personnes qui ne traverse jamais le
périph
oui oui bah ma soeur maintenant que
l'habitat paribas c'est fabien spleen un
peu plus du tout sortis mais pour dire
que vous venez de saint rémy les
chevreuse dans la grande ville de
l'autre côté de l'autre côté je suis
passé de l'autre côté de la force qui
alors le postulat de cette vidéo c'est
quoi ces où vous êtes dire un moment
trop de gens ne connaissent pas la
banlieue il faut que je remonte d'une
manière parodique mais je peux raconter
tout en fait
a la base je suis humoriste à un
spectacle et il y aquelques ya plus de
plus d'un an j'ai joué mon spectacle à
ses amis et on s'est dit tiens ce serait
une occasion parce que je travaille
quelqu'un si je dis on sait je parle de
sophie teulière et moi dit son nom c'est
à dire voilà on s'est dit ce serait bien
de parler de la ville vous qu'on veuille
jouer parce qu'il ya plein de gens je
sais qu'il ya quand ils voient ce
terminus sur le plan is as que ça existe
vraiment loin ça fait peur c'est loin du
coup on a fait une première vidéo où
j'ai présenté la ville et a eu pas mal
de succès pendant qu'ils succès dans la
ville et ça nous a donné envie de
dans de faire une suite en ayant moins
peur parce que la première fois on est
venu où s'est caché avec notre caméra
demandez pas aux gens et là on s'est dit
on va vraiment organiser un gros truc on
s'est dit tiens ce serait bien d'aller
voir les gens et puis après on s'est dit
ah d'emmener quelqu'un là-bas ce serait
un bon argument pour faire découvrir la
ville et puis après on est venu l'idée
de leur prendre rendez-vous en terre
inconnue
alors heureux qu'est ce que le public
andy ya des personnes qui croient
il ya des personnes qui lui ont pris
vraiment au premier degré vraiment
vraiment on a eu des lises à la
parisienne que j'envoie elle a eu un
message atroce de quelqu'un qui lui dit
ah c'est pas à 25 ans qu'on découvre le
monde tire autour de nous il ya des gens
qui ce qu'on s'amusait à doubler oui
j'ai encore en contre comme dans
l'émission alors qu'ils parlent français
c'est un ami aux dernières nouvelles et
du coup il ya des gens qui nous ont dit
ah pis pour toi vous doublez on parle
français c'est un milieu non il ya des
gens que leurs propres intérêts
c'étaient les premiers c'est tout les
premiers ressentis vous avez eu quand
vous êtes parti sur paris les jours vous
venez de saint rémy les chevreuse et ce
qu'il ya le feu chez vous oui non plus à
quoi maintenant rester le truc qui m'a
le plus marqué c'est quelqu'un quand
j'étais à la fac match je venais de
sarine tous les jours je vous ai entre
deux et trois heures de transport par
jour pour aller à la fac et est rentré
chez moi mais ça fait du bien mais oui
ma part quand tu temps pour moi je
réfléchis voilà on pense voilà on pense
beaucoup jeu et moi il y avait quelqu'un
dans ma fac qui me disent ah mais il
paraît que en banlieue pour le bus il ya
des horaires et on sentait que dans sa
tête c'était une lointaine légende je
connais quelqu'un qui est parti un jour
la barre et qui mali il ya des horaires
mais ouais je sentais que ça allait
c'est un peu flipper que j'aille que
j'habite aussi loin maintenant on n'a
pas la même notion de ce qui est loin
oui mais voilà et pour eux c'était aussi
pour changer l'image qu'on se fait de la
banlieue en soit là c'est plutôt le 78
c'est pas le 93 vous allez servir
l'autre tout le tour en fait il ya déjà
qui aimerait qu'on fasse d'autres vidéos
comme ça c'est pas prévu pour le moment
mais c'est vrai que moi chez moi j'avais
envie oui 2
montrer aux gens n'ayez pas peur d'aller
là bas c'est très sympa il ya plein
d'endroits sympas
après c'est vrai qu'il ya des gens qui
nous ont dit monde c'est une banlieue
sympathique quoi voilà comme à paris
après je serai ravi de changer l'image
que les gens ont d'autres banlieues mais
après je les connais pas bien j'ai parlé
mais moi ce que je dis souvent je suis
sur youtube je suis pas documentariste
donc c'est plus difficile pour moi de
parler d'un endroit que je ne connais
pas donc dans l'idée c'est juste une
vidéo comme ça où ça commence à me dire
il ya des trucs parfois nous fait 106
ans il veut j'imagine que ça donne à
réfléchir oui c'est ça c'est ça bah je
pense il ya une bonne idée si si j'ai si
on arrive à être est quelque chose qui
parce que là ce qui a marché aussi c'est
que c'était nouveau c'était la première
donc les gens découvrent le concept donc
ça amusant et me dit si on fait une
suite je ne sais pas si ça va même
succès je ne sais pas on verra
en tout cas je l'espère pour que j'anime
et normalement ça devrait fonctionner
car rien faire parce que j'ai vraiment
bien rigolé un bassin olympique et
sportif français non en lice est mal
gérée en tout cas on se comprend les
ouzbeks le dialecte internet 8 le film
on craque merci à vous
la batterie à 10 ans situe à guyancourt
la salle de concert a vu passer de
nombreux artistes comme les bandes pas
sous des vents de passe les wampas ils
vont passer wampas la grande sophie ou
encore qui dit kane alors disons après
faisons un point avec stéphane ridard
chargé de la programmation
le pari est réussi je pense pour pour
poursuivre sur cet aspect de banlieue
c'est vrai que à notre niveau certains
agents artistiques par exemple peuvent
avoir des difficultés à envoyer leurs
artistes dans les salles de banlieue
même si c'est la belle banlieue donc
parfois on indique que lui en cours ça
se trouve à côté de versailles ça les
rassure ça a été le cas pour julian
perretta qui viendra donc le jeudi 11
mai et deux jours plus tard il sera
l'elysée montmartre à paris
mais parfois il peut y avoir aussi des
histoires de concurrence entre les
salles parisiennes et des talents
en proche banlieue donc les agents
préfèrent envoyer leurs artistes
directement aux provinces c'était le cas
sur jim perretta normalement y avait que
cinq dates en france et j'ai réussi à
négocier avec l'agent et le manager pour
que cet artiste anglais viennent se
produire à la batterie en échange d'une
journée de résidence à veille le
mercredi pour préparer justement ces
cinq jours de concerts y la france
il a fallu que la batterie s'impose
comme salle de concert comme référence
dans le 78 là vous parlez des années
allant par exemple qu'ici c'est vrai
qu'il faudrait aussi par dont il faut
tenir compte de la concurrence entre
guillemets mais voilà on est on est ami
avec tout les taux de collègues dans les
salles chinoises
mais c'est vrai que un agent artistique
qui doit faire des choix et parfois il a
en effet décidé entre saint germain en
laye trappe guyancourt on est plutôt
bien positionné parce que le
l'équipement est vraiment de qualité à
la fois sur l'accueil technique
l'accueil des artistes et puis ben je
sais pas par exemple un artiste comme
jean louis murat cas quand même 100
caractères vous indique que voilà c'est
un très très bel équipement alors que
lui il a quand même tourné partout en
france dans quasiment toutes les salles
peut-être est-ce plutôt là c'est plutôt
ration dix ans après il ya une très
grande liste d'artistes qui seront
passées il était prévu de donner moi des
exemples d'artistes vraiment mais bien
vivant dans les grande sophie on a
ouvert en mai 2007 donc c'est vrai que
j'ai pas faire la liste de tous les gens
normaux qui sont passées mais on essaye
de représenter un petit peu toutes les
esthétiques et d'ailleurs c'est un pôle
musique de toutes les musiques c'est à
dire qu'il ya aussi fait vrai la musique
classique des musiques du monde
les musiques actuelles alors c'est vrai
que ce qui est peut-être le plus visible
ce sont les noms des artistes de
musiques actuelles à musique actuelle
c'est le rock le reggae le hip hop
donc c'est vraiment hypocrite james ils
disent là vous parlez des wampas en
chanson n'a eu qu'à relire écouter enfin
la liste elle est vraiment trop long
vous imaginez
déjà ça au moment de la construction
c'était la langue c'était le pari c'est
vrai qu'avec le maire de l'époque
puisque madame le maire est arrivé là en
novembre le tarnec avec françois de
ligne et son prédécesseur dont c'était
quand même fixé comme objectif qu'au
bout de cinq ans il fallait que la salle
soit soit positionné parmi les salles
vraiment phare du au moins du
département le pari est réussi puisque
la actuellement au niveau de notre
public on va dire on à 20% de be an
courtois et 80% divine loi sachant que
ça déborde aussi sur les autres
départements la province comme ce sont
des artistes un petit peu tête d'affiche
ou qui font peu de dates en france
donc en fait vraiment vous aver en
public c'est les gens se renseignent
c'est la salle de concert référence sur
saint quentin en yvelines en effet
maintenant avec tous les outils de
communication on parlait de youtube mais
voilà on a suffisamment d'outils
maintenant pour que les gens soient
informés là ce que je voulais juste
indiqué c'est que pour notre mois
anniversaire le mois de mai on a
labellisé tout le mois de mai sur des
concerts de tête d'affiche sur un tarif
qui est à 10 euros donc c'est vraiment
très peu cher de l'indre perretta il à
30,2 euros l elysée montmartre
donc voilà c'est vraiment des cadeaux
qu'on fait pour notre public pour le
remercier tous ces gens qui sont venus
sur les dix années de nous suivre donc
il faudra se dépêcher parce que les
places seront chères la salle elle fait
que 600 places donc voilà sur des
artistes comme esy kennenga ne écrivain
découvrir d'autres pour ses 10 ans alors
on démarrera le bal entre guillemets le
5 le vendredi 5 mai avec
las un concert qui gratuit ouvert à tout
le monde madame le maire d'ailleurs
présentera un petit peu le mois des
festivités et on a proposé un groupe qui
s'appelle bazar et bémol qui m'épate et
d'afficher un groupe prometteur en
chansons un petit peu les petits frères
des ogres de barback se situe entre les
ogres de barback et les zebda parce que
vous donnez aussi la chance voilà alors
ces gens là on les accompagne depuis à
peu près trois ans on les aide et
progressivement les commence à faire des
salles parisiennes il tombe bien en
province donc nous ma disposition
d'autres outils pour des résidences donc
ces artistes peuvent travailler pendant
trois quatre jours dans la salle à
partir dû tourner ensuite donc c'est ce
qu'on a proposé à bazar est démolie ils
viennent d'ailleurs la de terminer la
semaine dernière trois jours de travail
donc on les retrouvera le 5 c'est
gratuit donc c'est vraiment ouvert à
tout le monde le lendemain donc sur le
même week-end le 6 mai on aura la chance
d'avoir un martiniquais qui s'appelle
esy kennenga qui est très très connu
dans sa communauté
aux antilles en fait il s'est vraiment
quelqu'un de très reconnu d'été nous il
ya trois ans à l'olympia c'est complet
donc voilà c'est 10 euros et en première
partie on programme giro qui est le
monsieur qui a ouvert la batterie le 14
mai 2007 de mémoire et donc là il
viendra en première partie en version
acoustique avec deux autres musiciens
donc on va dire c'est une soirée assez
métissée la semaine suivante le 9 mai on
présente une des légendes
du reggae à savoir toots and the maytals
en première partie sera programmé à
kayes bkc le leader de midnight donc
tout ça ce sont des noms qui parlent
vraiment au spécialiste du reggae c'est
vraiment tout symptôme est en lice pour
ridge des artistes que ça soit requis
pop
alors voilà pas de hip hop on retrouvera
ça un petit peu plus tard dans la saison
parce que le groupe de hip hop
qui devait qui devait venir sur le mois
anniversaire n'étaient pas encore prêts
ils sont sur le plateau l'âge d'or du
rap qu'il est passé à bercy ils
viendront un petit peu plus tard à la
batterie mais on a un florilège en est
en effet de deux musiques métissées
puisqu'on aura aussi les béninois du
poly rythmo donc en a plein de choses à
découvrir en ce moment mais alors on
peut acheter les billets quand juste
vous avez très ouverte s'est ouvert la
3w la batterie demi en cours point fr et
dans tous les magasins qui vendent de la
billetterie donc à très bien vous irez à
bahia avons réussi à nous est bloqué non
ok très bien très bien je vous remercie
d'être venu sur le plateau c'est la
forme de ce set 8 les invités
bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]